the united states has approved the u.s
the sec has approved the volt crypto
industry revolution and tech etf which
is one a mouthful but two his goal is to
provide investors with exposure to
publicly traded companies with exposure
to bitcoin so obviously the bitcoin etf
has not yet been approved so the next
best thing according to the volt
crypto industry revolution and tech etf
is to buy the equity of companies that
have bitcoin exposure now if you want to
get bitcoin exposure it the first
question i have is why they called it
the volt crypto industry uh revolution
and tech etf and not the volt bitcoin
industry revolution and tech etf maybe
regulators wouldn't allow them or
there's some other reason but that's one
question that is unanswered now the fund
is the fifth etf that the san
francisco-based investment advisor has
launched and the fund which will not
hold any crypto assets directly will be
listed on the new york stock exchange at
least eighty percent of the fund's net
assets are going to be invested in
quote-unquote crypto stocks those are
stocks that have some exposure to
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies the
remaining 20 will be invested in more
traditional stocks to offset the risk of
the funds focused portfolio now when you
start to think about this if you're
going to create an etf and you're going
to tell everyone that you're going to
give them exposure to actually
publicly traded companies that have that
other exposure to bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies you're essentially
saying hey give me your money and then
i'm going to get you indirect exposure
to these assets
but if you only put 80 of the money into
those companies and the other 20 just go
in traditional stocks it kind of defeats
the purpose of what you're trying to
accomplish now companies that are
potentially going to be included in the
etf or things like microstrategy
marathon bit farms etc and what everyone
has their eyes on is the actual bitcoin
etf so this feels like kind of a
watered-down version of what folks are
trying to get to so if we can't actually
get the bitcoin etf instead now we have
this idea of a traditional etf that
holds stocks that then hold the asset so
it's indirect exposure underlying it but
if we're going to approve these
it's about time we approve the bitcoin
etf now the bitcoin etf has two
different ways to do it you can have one
based on futures or you can have one
based on actual bitcoin and what
ultimately now seems to be the rumor is
that the real bitcoin kind of in air
quotes etf is not the one that is likely
to get approved but instead of futures
based etf is the one that is likely to
get approved there are all sorts of cost
and all sorts of slippage etc concerns
with a future-based etf around bitcoin
compared to the real bitcoin etf but we
have to be patient we have to wait to
see what actually happens no one knows
there's over a dozen pending
applications
for bitcoin etfs everyone from skybridge
to arc to fidelity to galaxy digital
block 5
and a number of others uh i believe that
we also have grayscales in there uh i
believe bitwise etc uh some of these
folks have put them forward some of them
have taken them out uh some of them have
resubmitted so that there's kind of a
constant revolving door of people trying
to get the approval i do not believe
that we will see just one single bitcoin
etf provider approved where essentially
regulators become a king maker they say
hey this is the winner instead what i
think is likely to happen is that the
regulators are going to say okay it is
time it is now time they had us in the
first half but in the fourth quarter it
is time we are going to approve a
bitcoin etf and they may say that
they're going to do it through real
bitcoin or through a futures-based
product they choose the futures-based
product what they're likely to do is
select two three four five different etf
applications approve them all and allow
the market to decide where the assets
will flow that competition for assets
flowing into a bitcoin etf it's going to
come down to a lot of different things
some of it is going to be around the
custody there may be institutions that
worry about a specific custody provider
or more attracted to another custody
provider there's going to be things like
fees if one charges two and a half or
three percent on the fund and somebody
else charges one you obviously get a
better financial performance from a fee
standpoint and then lastly is what i
call familiarity right what is the thing
that gives you peace of mind there are
certain brands that have filed for a
bitcoin etf that everyone knows their
household names among institutional
investors and so they probably feel more
comfortable allocating to those funds
compared to a startup or some sort of
brand new entrant to the market i can
argue and so do many others that that's
not fair or that isn't necessarily the
best investment strategy but i think
that will absolutely play into the
institutional investor's decision as to
where they put their dollars when it
comes to a bitcoin etf now i also think
that we not only are going to see brand
new funds get the approval and start the
bitcoin etf we know that there's a
number of bitcoin etfs that have been
approved in canada and other markets uh
and then on top of that we've also seen
things like the bitcoin trust or other
crypto asset trusts from bitwise etc
that are on u.s exchanges and so when
you start to look at what's already in
the market even though there are no
bitcoin etfs available in the united
states markets you could quickly see
people taking the ones in canada trying
to cross-list them into the u.s and you
could also see the current asset
managers that have traded trust in the
united states converting them to etf
structures that provide the redemptions
and other things that etfs provide and
so ultimately i think a bitcoin etf
approval is likely folks like those over
at bloomberg eric and the team they have
about 75 confidence i've seen them
publicly talking about that a bitcoin
etf will be approved before the end of
the year we'll see but i do think that
it's likely to come i think that we will
not only see brand new funds get
approved and started and have multiple
of them so there's true competition and
a free market will settle where the
assets flow but i also think you're
going to see the conversion of the trust
into etfs over time and you'll also see
people from other jurisdictions like
canada and elsewhere try to cross list
into the u.s so once that approval
happens i think it is going to get
absolutely bananas you are going to see
assets flow into these structures
because there's a ton of folks sitting
on this island saying i want to get the
allocation i know that i need the
allocation but i can't do it in existing
structures i can't invest in a private
fund i don't want to invest in the trust
because there's no redemptions etc those
people they've got a lot of money and
when this etf gets approved there is
going to be massive asset flows into
these assets in my opinion right john
this is a step in the right direction um
it's a little unfortunate to see that
they delayed the actual bitcoin etfs
till late november at the earliest um
simply just kicking the cane down the
road i view this volt etf as someone who
has set up a structure basically to get
management fees on it like any
traditional etf like the s p 500 if you
wanted to break it down and actually
invest in those companies um you could
and not pay that management fee but it's
really a big hassle to do it most of
these companies either have bitcoin on
their balance sheet um are in bitcoin
related space i don't like the idea that
it's
labeled as a bitcoin etf in the sense of
only 80 will be involved in
cryptocurrencies and 20 more traditional
assets so that's a little different but
um
i don't know we'll see how much money
actually flows into it i think it's
interesting because like
as a retail investor most retail
investors if not all of them just
traditionally buy uh bitcoin directly
right they get exposure to the asset
directly by buying bitcoin itself
institutional investors are different
right for a bunch of regulatory reasons
and complications uh they like to
diversify and buy the etf or the other
uh kind of ability to get exposure to
the asset traditionally that's been
greyscale's trust right which has
essentially held a monopoly on uh the
institutional market in the
institutional capital flowing into the
space that for a long time created a
massive premium in the space that has
come down to a discount over the last
few months but traditionally over the
last few years that had created a
premium on the price but now as these
other uh kind of vehicles get approved
for them to get exposure into bitcoin
whether it's you know public equities
that own bitcoin or have exposure to
bitcoin or an eventual etf that uh gives
them direct exposure to bitcoin itself
these are all good things right this is
going to push the price up on the demand
side we already know the supply side
that's situated uh it's constrained we
know exactly how much is going to come
out it's programmatic et cetera so all
we're really looking at is the demand
side and the etfs are very very very
important because the institutional
capital is where we're going to see
massive inflows on the demand side and
this is where the price can really
appreciate so i think whether it's kind
of a step in the right direction where
we end up actually getting that etf
approved within the next six eight ten
months
is very important and i think from a
retail investor's perspective this is
something that people should watch
because it's going to make the price
appreciate on bitcoin much more rapidly
than it would on kind of just retail
investors continue to adopt it and
continue to get while it's continuing to
be brought into the network